hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to homesick starring
markiplier this is actually the sequel
to a new home starring Mark Blair I
don't know if it was like starring me
but I know that I was in it and then it
was awesome so if you haven't seen that
yet go check it out in the description
below because it's actually a really
good story and I thoroughly enjoyed it
which means that I'm probably gonna
thoroughly enjoy this one but we don't
know the future no one knows what's
gonna happen
hello welcome to home sig starring mark
bar you know that this game is a sequel
to another game right and you've played
watched it no of course I know that
awesome I just wanted to make sure you
want jumping into the middle of the
series like a weirdo wouldn't want to
confuse you I'm not a weirdo are you by
chance doing a let's play over here yeah
that's awesome you better link me to it
so I can watch unless you're mark
himself in which case that won't be
necessary hey it is me anyway I just
wanted to warn you that this game will
last longer than the typical let's play
episode but you shouldn't rush through
it just plan for a long episode of
multiple parts so get ready for that
everybody spoiler much take your time
and inspect everything into make your
way through the game or you'll end up
getting yourself stuck and not knowing
what you're supposed to do and would you
like to see the controls and some bits
god dammit stop giving me a tutorial I'm
smart
alright just know that you can change
the game to Buffalo in baby mode at any
time using the baby bottle item in your
inventory the game will be much easier
but you must I don't need it I'm an
expert Pro these games I know exactly
what I'm doing
bedroom mark crawls out of bed his sleep
disturbed by an intense need to use the
bathroom oh I can't focus right now I
have to pee so badly
I think the cons outweigh the pros of
peeing in here I think that oh okay well
you told me oh this is gift from a fan
thank you for being awesome this time I
actually have my personality with me and
not a douche personality starting time
to find the time to read all the letters
I get but I do my best just not in the
middle of the night and now what I have
to pay I keep my diary in my room now
instead of out in the open I'm so smart
it scares me
I say that to myself a lot I keep some
personal effects here the code has been
changed from the ever obvious birthday I
got badly oh wait okay left hallway it's
still a farz with flowers in it okay
running running running because I need
to pee is intense
no but stabbers in here ah let's just
give a lot of time for this one really
let it sink in how awkward me peeing in
a game that I'm playing is we can move
on with the story that's gonna be good
and whatnot Oh would you like to watch
Oh hygiene this is just lessons for all
the kids stay in school don't do drugs
drugs and never mind out of hands up off
to use itself from the shower you're
gonna be a bust
you'll never get away from me thank you
for taking the time to say that very
slowly you can run but you can't hide so
run okay bye don't need to tell me twice
oh well this is a problem run run run ha
ha ha ok
okay well I'm dead that didn't last very
long
you can do better than that try again
god damn it
this is gonna be a series of stupid
things
well [ __ ] blown baby mode don't taunt me
with your whatever the fancy word is for
not being nice I was doing the whole
time and I'm not a dum-dum again stupid
nightmares that's how I sound if you
didn't know I need some good rest
tonight so I'll be ready for tomorrow so
give it up Jimmy talking about dreams
I'm talking to myself cuz that's what I
do for a living for nearly a week mark
of lambs force to live outside of his
own body some sort of evil spirit hi
ejected and used it as a new home the
name of the game the spirit rejected
Mark's friend so badly they must have
felt like Wade where this 5th birthday
party
luckily mark was too pro for the spirit
and reclaimed the body so to make up for
all the times to supply bail
marking his car's friend bladder crap
weight also title on them hoes they set
up camp hey no need to be that mean -
Wade only I get to be that mean - Wade
oh is jam and music well here we are
miles from the nearest store and we've
got no phone signal or a way to wipe
after you use the bathroom again
more toilet references great so should
be relaxing saw like some terrible
happenstance will turn our phone into a
[ __ ] experiences Oh Lord thanks wait
you're such a cheerful sort I got the
cool I don't know what I got the cooler
so there's only a few more things left
now does it have beer bills this why did
you bring a styrofoam cooler you didn't
know wait he does not like the sound of
styrofoam it must have just slipped my
mind you did say something about not
doing that hah well please don't make
that sound
this trip is supposed to be relaxing
before we can do any relaxing we need to
get everything set up I'll volunteer to
gather up some wood for the fire really
why would you volunteer for a job like
that see what you want but those pole
dancing lessons have increased my
strength it'll be no problem for me nice
I'll get the rest of the stuff out of
the car and wait we'll set up all the
tents how nice VM Weiss is ooh sounds
cooler I don't know why I'm making whit
Bob talk like that I know exactly why
I'm making Wayne tags like that but oh
well I'm in a spin is tan I don't know
why I made him talk like that either I
over the time when I play these RPG
Maker games I uh
I tend to wander a bit with my voices
it's a beat-up old picnic table with a
bunch of illegible nonsense well it's
good for me it's a bucket of fresh water
great I'll leave this here so you caught
the wood once I find enough okay how am
I gonna get the wood okay nevermind I
guess I'm just gonna punch down a tree
with my bare hands cuz I'm so man laying
prone awesome or something hey come here
butterfly butterfly
I know but if I come back is that
supposed to be a sign or a hint or
something yeah maybe that alright let's
go find the word hold no one kill that
look would I found some wood but it
probably belongs to a beep beaver beaver
and he works so hard for it too why was
why would I care I needed more you
heartless monster you're so gonna get
the bad end
you got wood for the [ __ ] screw you I
don't care about no stupid beaver maybe
I should care about Queen I can't save
so I guess it's just it Wow care about
no beaver did I need more I don't know
if I needed more wood oh boy
jokes okay I got the wood
leave this here so oh I need to find
more wood so I'm assuming that that's
not gonna lead me to the bad end and
actually there's gonna be something here
wood perfect nothing like having wood in
the morning
oh these jokes are so classy wait no I
didn't mean it like oh sure okay not
ambiguous three fragments great great
good well how old is this thing still
standing I am NOT doing good on the
reading front so I need an axe to knock
that down to be able to cross that
bridge but I need the axe to be left
here till I find enough wood tree use
boss oh oh I can do it now oh well why
didn't I take it with me if I was going
in the woods anyway I'll take damn axe
okay so bear fine handsome you're going
down mr. tree I swing a mile long
diagonally Wow what it's crappy axe
broke put some blacksmith who made this
thing huh where's the blacksmith
references okay oh I guess it's good
that all the wood I'm finding is
convenient pre-cut stacks
so what could be better reward for your
efforts in a chunk of dead wood you got
some more firewood
congratulation for me I'm never Li not
going in there without a light source
okay yeah big bubble blowing baby didn't
know I said that to active all right so
is that enough wood now can I go on my
merry way is that gonna be enough this
is a tree foot very clever you know the
hardest thing about pitching a tent wait
I just realize how that sounded
they say pretend I never say that well I
guess we're gonna pretend we're not
gonna say a lot of things when it comes
to sexual jokes I shout them at the top
of our lungs
I don't censor myself just just watch
the episode of besieged again hey chop
chop get some wood so we can start chop
chopping it sorry Bob I'm very sorry
it's Wade's car he was forced to drive
since there are a lot of potholes on
this road good I guess we just hate Wade
with a burning passion would you like to
take this wood y-yes yes you would
nothing's worth the punch okay so now I
got enough wood or else a I really don't
know where I'm gonna get more wood so
I'm just under the assumption that this
is enough just three foot enough can't
fire safety is very important you are
after all the only one okay private of
wood Wade Wade god damn it Wade oh I can
go south uh sorry I didn't see that that
was my bad all right good out of my face
butterfly
we will hole in the ground Christopher
Nolan must have written this pit because
it's deep
you found Deku sticks land I mean just
regular sticks okay now that I want
through the menial task of getting all
the firewood for the fire now we can get
the story started I can have a horrible
nightmare descend upon me and everything
go horribly wrong mark and his friends
finish setting up the camp got a fire
going to sit around and unwind before
they went to bed or yes I should say
went to ground humor we got tell scary
stories but if you have to be worn down
first how did it get into your body in
the first place I'm stressed out from
moving into the new house that alone
we've tried to keep up with you guys and
my fans with a bit too much but the
spirit can take your body again can he
no but not for a lack of trying
he's constantly giving me nightmares and
trying to harass me I wouldn't be
surprised if he followed us here boy
what if he takes one of us don't be such
a big bubble on baby as long as you're
not in a bad place metal is harmless
good thing we're just insulting you over
and over again just emotionally right
because if intelligence is a part of it
we may need to get Wade out of here it's
a pretty crazy supernatural powers I can
conjure up monsters and create illusions
but even being in my body during this
time I know special powers I mean aside
from being incredibly handsome of course
I read somewhere that spirits can only
live without a body for seven days then
they have to move on I choose to remain
a lost spirit forever kids they act what
I did all the spirit did was buy a bunch
of bread and medical equipment yeah the
bread was just to piss me off
by reminding me of a certain game you
know who you are game but I don't know
about the others I guess they mean when
they say identity theft can happen to
anyone
jokes I'm glad you found all this brown
sticky stuff mark huh wait what are we
talking about the firewood brown and
sticky get it because they're snakes
you walk into a monster day I drove I've
got the keys yeah well that's enough
clunky expedition for one night I'm
gonna retire and probably not be
possessed by ghosts
sounds like a plan yeah me too
do you have to do everything we do you
yes so Margot his friends drifted off to
sleep but the Sandman better get his act
together because mark found himself
awake in the middle of the night once
again shine now ever fear snoring was
the cause of the problem Bob I got tell
him to put a blanket over his head or
something
yes in the middle of the night the best
way to spend a camping trip is killing
my own friends all right
diary I had to bring my diary luck it's
important to know that it's a diary not
a journal journals are for children okay
finally I save did something happen now
who's snoring let me just climb into the
tent
definitely not Brokeback Mountain style
it's going to cut Earl to be Wade
Oh must be the gutter of Bob wait a
minute
where is he we'd have a bad dream and
make Bob sleep with him
good question okay anything else in here
my beater blow skills are proved to be
quite effective earlier okay so if it's
not wait whoa whoa jeez this bloody room
you can cuddle up with me I come big
spoon okay first of all where are you
why are you sleeping in my friends ten
take it off why are you so filthy smell
like Sheffield exclusively with fire and
serve all I would definitely be the big
spoon yo kid yourself yeah it wasn't
nobody in here so I made myself at home
I hate them hot dogs too there's nobody
else eating them you need to go yeah
okay yeah go on can't just take people's
stuff without even ask for the road was
gonna happen cuz it's me get it is that
hard no we're like oh go right now I
have to figure out what Bop way to
vanish - hmm good question I should
probably avoid the word vanish less I
trigger some PTSD it's amazing how
people still give me crap about that I
beat the game so I don't need to be
reminded to talk about it ever again I
think I remember hearing some shuffling
behind my tent I should check the
Northern Pass first I did everything
else least have to take a turn for the
creepier well I would hope so
considering that this needs to be a whoa
so we did tag along the Krays but Sarah
just decided to sprint in front of me
and then gone instantly like he was
never there clearly hasn't taken Barbara
Wade's body it I just have to find them
before he does I mean not that anyone
who'd want Wade stinky but jeez this is
getting to the insulting wait wait does
not stink unless it's at the end of a 12
hour livestream then he stinks very much
okay ah a note is this going to be
Slenderman I know must be from Baba wait
let's take a look here oh this isn't a
node this is I'll put it back
that didn't count it's been so long
since slender ah crap son of a [ __ ]
welp here we go back into the slender
slender woods looks like a place for
visitors to sign a guestbook here really
is there extra paper to write out my
well before I get mad I'd probably not
okay
good bye everybody cried cruel world I'm
about to be Myrtle eyes by the
Slenderman which hasn't happened in a
long time
I guess I didn't play that one crappy
slender game recently but it's been a
while since a good one I think I heard
that there might have been an update to
slender the arrival but I'm not sure oh
boy another page page 2a not even gonna
tell me what they say just - it's just a
big - written on the front of it I mean
it's weird because you think about
solara-bike
okay geez hello
I was rather sudden I think I probably
can climb those vines up there I'm gonna
go up and go here I can see so far from
up here okay good hey there's a page
okay so was that all I was supposed to
do uh okay then yeah anyway it's weird
considering that you know five nights at
freddys kind of the new slender and I
should be able to hop over the log if I
think if I'm going downhill I don't
think I could make it back up though so
basically it's Pokemon rules I bet that
jerk chasing me would have a hard time
jumping over these slender as he is yeah
obviously skips legs done he don't do
squats
oh [ __ ] well really well for okay I'm
okay
oh I know what I need to be oh I forgot
those
that's not it that's not it all right
okay so back up so what I need to do is
I need to figure out a way to like hey
so I just gotta go straight down I can't
go get that point why can't I get their
note I can't and I get the nod oh I know
what I need to do ah I know what I need
to do okay I know what I need to do I
know what I need to do I know what I
need to do I know what I need to do
hahahahahaha douche hi such a prick oh
good literally deliver me the Ranger
danger
Sloan Ranger danger no god damn it no no
no no no okay
damn okay that was actually pretty
stressful I thought I was gonna die okay
so I did it all right I'll just need to
get through the rest of this and then I
should be relatively good so I got four
of a payload there's the next one hey
it's five of eight good for me okay
we're going down we're going down we're
going down not like that slide about get
away from me we're not going down oh
okay so now that I got all this cleared
out of the way I can do is get on with
my life up here oh this isn't a death
trap at all of course not
I'm totally fine totally fine totally
fine
oh the noise is getting conspicuous now
wait was that up was that another path
where there might have been a page is
there another path whether I'm at a bit
of it okay nose did it okay so he's
gonna pop out any moment now I know it
is how's this dead-end so I don't know
if the dead ends actually have a page
that's why I'm going up there just be
sure okay everything's hunky-dory oh boy
another route up that I can scatter on
the path okay what do we got in store I
can see so far so smart about things and
stuff okay middle is bad the right is
good right then right okay so right is
where the page is but I need to go down
and write first and then continue right
okay I got it I got I got I get but
that's only the seventh page that means
that there's got to be more stuff I
don't know if he's gonna pop out at me
but whatever 708 come on skip skip skip
to my Lou he's being awfully inactive
for being this late in the night okay so
I have seven pages okay there is I
shouldn't have said anything
there we go god it's bringing back a lot
of Slenderman memories in fact slender
memories I think was actually a game so
I'm almost done what's the last page why
do I need to do this anyway why am i
hidden in the recesses of my own mind
okay was it up this way okay goodbye oh
[ __ ] what was I supposed to do it's kind
of no path there maybe there could have
been a way I could have jumped over
something or something oh really
god damn you how am I supposed to be
able to oh I know this log here I need
to really okay alright okay alright I
gotta push it from the correct side
first cuz we're not dinguses yeah
pushover oh no no
I [ __ ] up [ __ ] up but I almost had
it
how was I supposed to know maybe because
it was playing it obvious to see anyone
could have known that
yeah that's I see a really good mechanic
though like I'm actually impressed by
that programming in this game now I just
have to escape okay so what now oh hey
yeah I got all your pages wait
don't kill me somebody games I haven't
played so much meat left uneaten surely
there's something you want right what
could I do to help you yes I want you to
pay me you big silly goose it's
officially slender man's voice wait what
what was that oh you know I wanna make a
pretty drawing and hanging on tree
instead we're proud of him I'm gonna be
an artist one day but goobers like you
come along and take him snatch him up
like they're half-price badminton
rackets wait so can I just give you the
paints back this is a library
you grab my beautiful I love it so of
course you will return it I mean you
need to face you from the relevant
distance and all that good yeah okay I
must see what my brother Jade before I
guess idiot give me the eyes that was
actually the secret mode in the original
Thunder that I'd ever played that's what
you meant
with the hewi man
well here's 20 bucks hand it over a
crisp $20 bill yeah that's all my money
I'll just be on my way now it was not uh
sweetheart
I mean $20 each oh good god well hello
that was weird
what that was what
there's something weird going my audio
oh crap
didn't what what happened is everything
okay I suddenly started getting weird
feedback in my audio is this Enderman
here gonna kill me
$20 each that's too much screw you oh my
god you guys don't know yet don't like
him just turn your back cover the
interest I'll take years old oh well god
damn it
Oh fine I'll give you the money
all this joke with totally worth it okay
cool beans
hand it over Chris hundred and forty
bucks ouch well I'll cherish them or
whatever and even do other guys today no
you're my face today I really need to go
now so I can fly my friends p.m. first
don't kill them oh you know I can't make
a promise like that baby your friends
later I can't stand when people do that
I Sam
then I explode their band from the end
bye on that note I'm gonna get out of
here thanks for the wonderful art no
thank you
Wow okay great thanks so much I really
appreciate a slender douche okay so that
didn't help me at all what is that I
didn't even notice the cooler gets
smashed that's weird
did way do it to spite Bob it was that
damn hobo scavenging for hot dogs either
way I guess I better grab up the pieces
wouldn't want anyone to think we're
filthy lures like that Slenderman okay
so that's good not good safe okay so
this is a long episode and long game
probably but I'm gonna take the time and
played in another episode so thank you
all so much for watching be sure to
check out a new home which was another
amazing fan game to check out little the
other amazing fan games that were played
in the past thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you developer for
taking the time to make this game I
really do appreciate these fan games I
really really
so thank you guys again and as always I
will see you option we took I got my
guys let's bring in the big guns and
Porsches King - please the monkey
doesn't further makeup monkey out of me